The general Hogan experience. So
you're, you're 100% in on ghosts.
I am now.
Tell me about why you're 100% in on
Sasquatch cause that that one is a,
that's more puzzling to me.
Well, just, uh, that it's,
it's a, again, a Gabriel Reese's,
uh, story was quite convincing.
Jeff Meldrum his research like in missing,
I would have talked to
her about [inaudible].
Belgium told me he cut his finger off.
He said if he could find out if Sasquatch
is really take a pinky off. I said,
if you cut your finger off to know that
Sasquatch is real, would you do it?
He goes, which finger? I'm like,
your pinky. Well, he's got casts.
He's got hair. I'm going
to Jamie, Jeff Meldrum,
M. E. L. D. R. U. N. D. he used to
be, it's in my room. He was a, he's a,
you know, he's a paleontological scientist
at the university of South Dakota,
but he can also be a silly man sometimes
you study things, you memorize them,
you pass a test, but you still silly
well lit. But you talked to him.
Did you think? Did you
feel he was a w? You know,
I open up my finger for nobody, man.
I ain't giving up a finger to find out
if Sasquatch is real. That's crazy.
You know, he's pretty
devoted to it. But, um,
it's been, you know,
Yeti the yak and Yeti story and all the
Yeti story and just the round the world.
Uh, just the, um, the sightings
that that people have had. Um,
I read a book, well, it was a book
called a diary in Alaska, housewife.
It was about a woman. She
wrote it, she, uh, left, uh,
in the 70s to move from Kansas to Alaska.
And her husband worked on the pipeline
and she tells a story one afternoon when
she was at her, you know, uh,
her window in the kitchen and
she went outside into the garden.
So she felt,
saw something went outside and
she smelled this really strong,
strong musky, musky odor.
And she saw this big,
huge shape at the corner of her garden.
Kind of disappear into the woods.
And I dunno, bear grizzly
[inaudible], who knows. Sure. Yeah.
How about town? Where are you
on trooper Cobre? Not at all.
I think it's nonsense. I think it's a
coyotes with mange. Yeah, I'm convinced.
Yeah. Okay. I mean, they've,
they've captured coyotes with mains.
It look like demons. How about moth?
Man, that's a neat story. Listen,
let's go back to big foot. Let's not,
you don't believe that these
kids think they're full of shit.
Let's go back to the moth man. Prophecies.
The, the bridge collapsing holes.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'm not,
I'm not gonna sit here and
argue on behalf of moth man,
but it's an intriguing story because
when you have multiple witnesses,
like as far as the UFO, I will
go back to a good foot. But the,
the aerial encounter, the, the school
children at the aerial, a school in,
in Zimbabwe, in the, uh, in
the 90s. You know the story,
John Mack was working on it.
No two beings landed in two different
craft and they encountered these
schoolchildren all in elementary school
and now they've come back and they're
interviewing them now in their adult time.
And it's amazing how
their stories synchronize.
Why would all of them inspire
to make something up? Okay.
We deal with two different
things and the moth mountain,
there were four really
credible kids there that
man,
the UFO thing is less preposterous
than anything because we are currently
sending spaceships into orbit.
We are currently sending probes
to Mars. We are, we're involved,
deeply involved in the
exploration of our solar system,
at least with these robots and drones
and things that we can control that that
all, all that makes 100% sense to me.
Big foot is interesting to me because
there was a creature called gigantic
[inaudible]. It was an
enormous primate that was a,
without a doubt lived
it. It's a real thing.
It was a bipedal hominid.
They think it was between eight
and perhaps even 10 feet tall.
It was a huge apelike creature and it
went extinct and the reason why they found
it is because there
was an apothecary shop,
I believe it was in the
1920s an anthropologist found
a tooth in its apothecary
shop in China. He talked to the
people. Where'd you find this?
He recognized it as a primate tooth.
They brought him to the site where they
found it and then they started finding
other pieces.
They found bones that re that seemed to
indicate that this thing was by Peatal.
And this is something that's accepted
in the paleontological paleontological
record.
This is like when anthropologists
look at the history of primates,
when they look at the, they think
this is a widely accepted real animal.
So
why? Why wouldn't it was real? Why? What's
the, why did it, why do you say that?
It couldn't have survived and uh,
and, and beyond extinction and, and,
and exist today in some
form. We don't know.
There's no evidence that's compelling.
Just like there's no illness fake.
They think they pretty much the film
is fake. The Patterson footage. Yeah.
That's for shit. I say it's
fake. Here's the thing.
If it looks like a man in a suit, no
animal looks like a man in a suit.
There's not a fucking single
current kangaroo out there.
Does that kinda person kangaroo suit?
I just, I just think Gabriel story,
Belle drums research, the book
that I read of the woman's
Gabrielle Risa story,
she was in the camping up there in one
of those Northern States, Washington,
and I believe she has video footage
of him shaking, shaking, shaking,
the shaking, the shaking, the
motor home that they were in. Yeah.
She was quite excited to tell me the
story and, and uh, quite vivid about it.
She said that it was, it
was scary. It was scary.
If there was a small popular look,
try finding a Wolverine, you know,
try finding RA RA or a super one of
these super sloths and the South American
jungle. Now these big slots, well,
there's one,
there's one scientist that has literally
risked his reputation and he's,
his whole fucking credibility is in demise
because he decided that he was going
to spend his life
looking for giant sloths.
And these indigenous people have pointed
them in the right direction and they've
recognized that there's, you know,
there's dung that seems to be sloppy,
dung that they've found and they're
trying to point him towards where these
things are. And the giant
sloths was a real creature,
but there's no real evidence that the
giant swath is currently alive. But the,
the thing is the vast wilderness of the
Amazon rain forest is so impenetrable.
It will be like trying to walk across the
earth and make a good audit of all the
creatures that are on it. You're not
going to run into them. And you know,
we many species are dying on this planet
right now for dirt, various reasons,
but there are many that are
being discovered, we never
even knew about before.
And you know,
the Northwestern forests
are pretty impeditive triple
to the Washington for us.
Interesting.
You said the location of the area where
if the thing crossed the Bering land
bridge and it came into the United
States, that's exactly where it would be.
It would be in that Pacific
Northwest because that's, you know,
as you walked down from Alaska and we've
heard the stories of loggers going in
there and seeing them more,
sensing them or because they're being
driven out of their environment,
hostile accident logging companies that
they think have been perpetrated by, uh,
by, you know, those, uh, by the Sasquatch.
Nobody wants to believe in Bigfoot more
than me. I work, I worked up in, uh,
in the Northwest territories.
I was a flex track, uh,
assistant mechanic on crawlers and I
was a road surveyor when I was a kid.
I worked for the department of public
works and we were up there and along the
[inaudible] river I had less river where
explorers would go in and they'd find
their heads and then never come back.
That can of big foot heads. No, no,
no good though. Human heads,
human hair, the headless Valley,
the headless river, no
honey river in a H and I,
but when I went up there and
was with the survey people,
there had been guys who've been
up there, you know, uh, you know,
years before me. And they,
and they said that Sasquatch was a common
thing that was spoken about among the
natives and among the
survey crews up there.
Do you ever see the Bobcat Goldthwait
movie Willow Creek? No. Outstanding movie.
Cat Goldthwait made a horror movie
about Bigfoot Bobcat Goldthwait.
The comedian made excellent
horror movies that, Oh my God,
that's like fire in the sky. Thought
good depiction. You would love it. Oh,
I will love it.
It's about a bunch of people that go up
there to try to replicate the Patterson
Bigfoot film sort of as a Lark. Oh,
they go up there for fun
and they encounter a real
Sasquatch. So Willow Creek,
it's called. Yes, it's really
good. I love that. I love that.
That spread is a 100% believer.
He believes he and I've had some
ridiculous conversations about it.
It'd be nice to go and and go into the
intense woods up there and maybe camp for
a weekend look, man DOE,
to see something like that,
a bipedal hominid that is
avoided detection for hundreds,
if not thousands of
years. It'd be amazing.
But they spoke from native Americans as
native Americans had more than a hundred
different names between
all the various tribes.
100 different names for Sasquatch.
I really, yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh,
ma was one of them.
You know that you saw that American
werewolf in London thing that is, uh, the,
the guy who created that
Pat, uh, Rob Baker? No, no,
that's Rick Baker. Baker.
I'm sorry. Yeah. Pat McGee,
who's the special effects
guy, created the one for me,
but Rick Baker designed it
originally, but he made a,
Pat McGee made a movie called OMOP, what
was it called? Omar primal scream CV.
But it's basically a horror movie
about Sasquatch and you know,
it's, it's incredibly compelling
to people. This is enormous.
Primates,
it's been avoiding detection living in
the forest among the indigenous people
say that they, they sometimes
grab children and take them.
I think that's because it used to be
a real thing. That's what I think.
I think that's because if,
if we all agree in scientists agree that
this gigantic Pythius was a real thing,
if that is the case,
then it's entirely possible that
one point at one point in time,
human beings were in direct contact
with them on a regular basis,
and those stories been passed down
through generation after generation.
The real question is, are they still here?
Because the people that are telling you
these stories, like when we talk about,
uh, people in North America,
it's widely accepted that
most native Americans,
they share a lot of genetics with people
from Siberia because Siberia is what's
close to the Bering land bridge. They
come down, these people eventually, many,
many, many, many, many thousands of years
migrated into America and they have,
so those are people that would
have been in contact 100,000,
whatever years ago if they don't know.
They know that these teeth that they
found from judge [inaudible] indicate that
at the, at least a hundred thousand
years ago, they were alive.
Does that mean they were
alive 50,000 years ago?
Very possibly fit like
a homo floresiensis.
You know that the Hobbit person that
you found this tiny little thing on the
Flores Island,
that thing they didn't even know that
was real until the two thousands and that
thing existed as recently as, I
think it was 13 or 14,000 years ago,
which is incredibly recent.
And this is a completely new discovery
that people found that there was a
totally different species of human
being that was very small, Lou,
the Chimp size brain, but it was human.
It used tools and it lived amongst humans.
So this thing, if they know it
lived a hundred thousand years ago,
it could have easily live
50, it might have lived 20,
so it lived 20,000 years ago. Today.
We just know way they're going fine.
Yeah. But there's, there's no
evidence of mammoths either, right?
We know they were real, but there's no,
like if someone said I saw a mammoth,
you'd be like, where do you
have a picture? No, no, no.
But I sensed it the fuck out of here
with your sensing mammas I think if you
did, if you put an Mt. Mt.
At a horrible avatar style military. Uh,
uh, let's say incursion into
some of the deep woods of
Northwest America. You might, you
might get traces, but coming down,
what a horrible thing that would beat it
to do. Excellent thing. We get footage.
I know, but then you're destroying.
That's a Pat McGee's
version of a great, yeah,
it's like kind of look grouped and yeah.
Wow. That's just a weird picture. No,
that's beautiful. It's
called primal rage. A neat,
neat look at the um, the
animatronics. Yeah. You see the,
that face right there, Jim? Yeah. When's
that coming out or is it that out?
Okay. Now for quite a while, primal
rage and, and from Willow Creek,
the Creek is really interesting cause
Willow Creek is like Blair witch style.
It's all like found footage. Like the
whole thing, like the, okay, here we are,
we're in the woods. You
know, like that kind of shit.
It's really Bobcat's a genius
is, he did a great job with it.
He's really good. It's like
compelling. It's exciting.
And even if I don't believe
in Bigfoot or don't,
don't believe it's currently alive,
just I know too many people that
are in the woods all the time.
I know too many people that are
hunters that are in the woods,
that haven't seen weeks and weeks in the
woods. And none of them I've seen shit.
They see bears walking on two
feet though. That's really normal.
And when you're in thick, dense forests,
bears walking on two feet and you
see him in the dusk. Oh my God,
I saw big foot. I'm convinced.
And then you really are convinced.
So then you go back and tell
everybody. Yeah, I think, you know,
basically just each individual as to
make their own minds up about all of this
stuff. And if you want to believe
it's just like your religion,
you know, I believe in mediumship.
I believe in the afterlife I have of
our consciousness and that's kind of my
religion. And who's to say, why should
I be disputed on that? You know,
I'm glad you believe. I'm
glad there's people I don't,
I'm glad there's intelligent people that
believe in silly shit. Well, you know,
look, uh, you know,
many people live in the Virgin Mary
cause Kathlyn and that's quite a myth and
many believe in the angel Moroni and the
golden plates and the magic spectacles
and, and many believe in Zeno, you
know, the Scientologists believe.
So I'm not going to go and say,
Hey, Oh, I dispute your belief.
There were no golden spectacles or there
were no gold and no, there was no Zeno,
no, there was no Virgin Mary. No.
I respect people's belief and they
realize that's what you believe and that's
what helps you, you know? And I, I would
never dispute that. And likewise, I,
I want to be respected for my belief
in spiritualism and mediumship.
And so there's a religion and skepticism
as well. I think there's this,
there's a, and I respect that
Gulf war. Yeah. But there's,
you know what I'm saying?
That there's a tendency to just
try to dismiss everything as being,
as believe the official
story of every single thing.
I know why that's good.
Because that empirical view will
be able to sort out the fake stuff,
the Hoke stuff from the real stuff.
If people have real scientific
minds and real, you know,
inquests they're going into
it. That's what's gonna.
That's what's gonna sort out
what's real and what isn't.
[inaudible].